was macht man dann dass diese der kinder
leben auf die 1500 meter über meer
in einem jahr kommen sie in die schule
das bedeutet sie müssten täglich mit der
bahn ins tal fahren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
seit 19 jahren gibt es nämlich keine
schule mehr auf der rigi
[Musik]
2018 beschließen junge eltern auf dem
berg das zu ändern
die initiative kommt vom hotel les
portes krauter hotels edelweiß gabriela
und jemand gregor träumen davon dass
ihre beiden kinder die ersten schuljahre
ohne druck eines herkömmlichen
schulbetriebes erleben dürfen
deswegen möchten sie wieder eine
gesamtschule eröffnen
ihr küchenchef benjamin jost und seine
frau lilly würden ihre zwei kinder auch
gerne auf dem berg zur schule schicken
das konzept einer kleinen naturschule
überzeugt sie sofort deswegen haben sich
die beiden paare zusammen getan ich aus
meiner schulzeit sehr einfach
mitgenommen dass das lernen allgemein
ist auch wenn ich hier in der küche mit
meinen mitarbeitern lernen dass man
daran beteiligt ist und dass das nicht
so zusagt und in so einer großen gruppe
gut funktionieren kann
weil wir aus unseren aus unserem sozial
körper merken dass sich immer welche
hervortun ganz automatisch und viele
sich aber auch zurück zurückziehen und
das ist ein bisschen daran den der
potenzial entfaltung einfach im
vorbeigehen gabriele ecke ist in diesem
hotel aufgewachsen und besuchte die
damals noch bestehende gesamtschule
sie übernahm das hotel von ihren eltern
und möchte ihren kindern ein freies
lernen ermöglichen so wie sie es erlebt
hat für mich ist natürlich ein
emotionaler klarheit ich bin sagt jörg
toppel moment das ist für mich vom
schutz immer noch dass er vor dem
schulhof 78 und sternbilder integriert
ist
dazu will ich mich auch um hätte ich
schön wetter könnte sie gewonnen und
sind einfach sache wenn ich mir wünschen
dass - also weniger die schweizer bieten
im august 2008 10 informieren die
initianten erstmals die öffentlichkeit
auf der regioplan ist ehrgeizig in einem
jahr schon wohnen sie die schule
eröffnen
außer den kindern und viel enthusiasmus
fehlt noch ziemlich alles ein
schulzimmer schulmaterial geld für löhne
und eine lehrperson und eine bewilligung
des kantons ein schulberater der auch
auf der gewohnt unterstützt die
elterngruppe ehrenamtlich usa liegen ist
dass man eine solide grundlage hat
das müssen auch im lehrplan orientiert
mehr werdet es konzept ausarbeiten den
entwurf vor dem konzept schon einmal
mental uhr
das ist mal davon das wird eine einzige
genveränderung
aber abgesehen dass rose wir mehrwert
schaffe und was ist das ziel ist ein
gerät zur sorge beispielsweise gemeint
so kommt um unterstützung wurde auch
hier mit oder läuft unser großes mehr
den zentralen fragen mehrheit 29-jährige
der kasse vom verein richtig änderungen
endnutzer und der rest wird arbeitseifer
nächste jahr stiftete etc
der ehemalige schülerinnen und schüler
leben immer noch auf der regel die
gesamtschule haben sie in guter
erinnerung
man müsse lernen sich konzentrieren sich
fokussieren oft nur mäßig jetzt wichtig
und glichen zwischen die macher beamten
zu erlösen
also setzt erklärt frauenpolitik und sie
haben auf uns konzentrieren
wichtig ist dass sie missachtet die
idylle ist natürlich spätestens beim
übertritt in die oberstufe vorbei in der
anschluss klasse im tal gibt es viel
mehr kinder
also ich hab ich sie zweimal 4 20
ich fühle mich nicht angesprochen und
die mentalität der raum bisher sage die
völlig benebelt kunden und völlig blöd
wenn die halle dann bekannt dass das
eine erlaubte musst dir selber gedanken
machen und die studiobühne und blut ist
und das handy tun überhaupt nichts oder
niki tatort hat rund 110 einwohnerinnen
und einwohner
viele häuser gehören feriengästen wir
sind die 1960 er jahren standen mitten
im dorf ein hotel und das hotel bellevue
dort wurden bereits ab 1902 kinder
unterrichtet auf private initiative der
hoteliers da hinten weil die familie
selber zehn kinder hatte
[Musik]
eine ihrer enkelinnen die heute 90
jährige ruth reinecke besuchte 1935 die
erste öffentliche schule auf der regel
[Musik]
ca im bahnhof hettstedter songs covert
racing sehen wo die autos versteckt sind
und decke steckt uhu früher wurden die
gäste im sommer mehrere wochen in den
hotels und schickten ihre kinder auch in
die regelschule
es gab zeiten da besuchten 36 kinder die
gesamtschule
zeitweise gab es sogar zwei schulhäuser
eines für die kinder auf der luzerner
seite eines für die kinder auf der
schweizer seite
im winter kämpften sich die bauernkinder
oft stundenlang durch die schneemassen
um rechtzeitig in der schule zu sein
[Musik]
jedoch sei die sind froh und sehr
stressig wachstumspolitik schlafen und
hetze sehr wohl eher espeter exakt india
verschlafen und sind muss also mit lang
lang heimat jetzt kurzer zeit
abgeschlossen sap ist gut so
also offenbar hat ihr glück
ein jähes ende der idyllischen und
prosperierenden zeit brachte 1961 der
brand des gran hotels
der tourismus brach ein schwinden der
arbeitsplätze zwangen die familien vom
berg ins tal zu ziehen
[Musik]
die klassen schrumpften und so wurde die
regelschule geschlossen
seither können die kinder auf zwei
seiten ins tal zur schule fahren auf der
schweizer seite der region an ziert die
schulgemeinde golder mit jährlich 63
1000 franken einen schüler zug an
werktagen immer morgens um 7
außer in den schulferien
[Musik]
derzeit führt zwei kinder von einem
bauernhof
im sommer steigen eine station weiter
unten noch zwei älpler kinder dazu
alle anderen mitglied im ticket dürfen
den zukauf benutzen
[Musik]
der vater der älpler kinder auf der
schweizer seite der rigi ist als pension
hier aufgewachsen
eine schule auf dem berg hätte ihn
damals schon gepasst gegangen
inzwischen hat er mit seiner frau selber
zehn kinder ein park sind schon
ausgeflogen wo ich bin im aufschwung und
der arbeits nachschauen und winzig und
unter dem titel
das könnte sein dass sie in zukunft
während der allzeit ihre kinder auch in
die regelschule schicken werden
aber noch gibt es die schule ja nicht
auf der luzerner seite fährt die bahn
von pfitzner auf die rigi dort arbeitet
marion fläche seit zwei jahren lebt sie
mit mann und kind auf rigi kaltbad und
sie wollen ihre tochter linda unbedingt
in die regelschule schicken also für uns
ist es sicher richtig
in unserer nähe
willich schamberger
[Musik]
ich bin froh wenn sie mal dann noch
gesagt den vorteil mit sich
und die halten auf kaufen
was sicher wichtiger punkt ist die über
900 familien und die wirklichkeit wenn
die kinder in schulen
im oktober ist aber noch immer nicht
klar ob es überhaupt klappen wird mit
der schule
[Musik]
unterstützung erhoffen sich die
initianten von der katholischen kirche
ihr gehört dieses haus die alte kaplanei
hier ging gabriel ja zur schule raum
steht meistens leer und darum ist
gabriella mit ihrem küchenchef baby
unterwegs zu einem gespräch mit
kirchenvertretern
für mich ist das relativ unentscheiden
das sag ich mal
ob das jetzt der raum würde dann anderer
raum aber ist natürlich eine tolle tolle
lage unter ist natürlich auch vor nicht
einmal schön vorbelastet sozusagen die
home bietet eigentlich alles was ein
buch der qualität ihrer kategorie uci
wiese für russe ich eigentlich direkt
orte talstation vom skilift rateteams
oft nachhaltig und unsere kinder können
mit dem schlitten eigentlich auf die
antwort werden sie bis in den winter
warten müssen
skifahren lernen die risiken da fast
gleichzeitig mit dem gehen falls es mit
der schule auf der wege klappen würde
wäre es wieder wie bei gabriela vor rund
40 jahren die beste schule war überhaupt
keine morgenluft schießt aber fahren bis
schulhaus und zum skilift
die alte schulzimmer wäre also auch für
die kinder heute ideal gelegen
der winter ist lang auf der rigi im
januar 2009 10 an der gv des
trägervereins der geplanten schule
beschließen gabriella und ihre
mitstreiter unter anderem dass der
elternbeitrag pro kind und monat 500
franken sein soll
[Musik]
und die antwort der katholischen kirche
ist endlich da eigentlichen
zusatzförderung allerdings mit
bedingungen wofür die sehr schwierig
sind mir dies relativ hoch 150 franken
pro tag zu tag macht das fast 2000
franken im monat und das belastet dieses
budget natürlich enorm stark wird in dem
moment mal eher später sind wir müssten
auch für den fall dass die katholische
stelle darum sauber brüste und freiheit
bilder landkarten kinderzeichnungen und
nicht einfach dürfe ihnen und dann hab
ich alles richtig zusammen rum und die
these dass ich mit ganz dass das niemals
vorstellen
das bedeutet in sachen schulzimmer
fangen sie wieder von vorne an was sie
nicht davon abhält trotzdem eine
lehrperson zu suchen sich so dass man
jetzt ihre stellen ausgeschrieben hält
die ist jetzt im beruf der
online-plattform von ihrer person ist
die maschine und sich einige sind einige
bewerbungen eingegangen
und mit 23 personen kontakt dürfen
beziehungsweise haben schon kontakt
immer wieder lockt ja wie sehr
zuversichtlich die person x factor um
endlich den druck gesorgt hatte sind
sehr interessiert sind sich bewusst um
was es geht
jeden mittwochnachmittag findet man die
regelkinder in der waldspielgruppe auch
bei klirrender kälte
jede box ins bad und der focus
sie sind bereits eine eingeschworene
gruppe
wenn alles klappt werden sie im sommer
in der neuen schule die ersten vier
schülerinnen und schüler sein
der schnee ist längst geschmolzen das
gebimmel kuhglocken das untrügliche
zeichen des beginnenden sommers es da
wird nur noch ein paar wochen bis zum
schulbeginn
jeden tag fährt es direktion spa des
hotels kaltbad mit der bahn auf die
autofreie regionen käme es ihr entgegen
wenn ihre kinder hier ihre ersten
schuljahr verbringen könnten chinesische
ganztagsschule lassen sie nach von
morgen bis am nachmittag sechs meter
kochen und essen sie mir natürlich viel
mehr flex und wird vom staufen und der
zweite grund ist natürlich wenn es mir
egal es gebe dass sie vorauszusehen sie
machen das in der natur und ich denke es
ist nach so schnell denn in der schule
und im maschinen und lernen und jetzt
muss auch etwas früher lernen das finde
ich schwarz
die gruppengröße vier personen können
vielleicht auf lange sicht schwierig
werden weil gefahr besteht dass das dann
relativ schnell wieder beerdigt werden
muss wo wir natürlich dann hoffen dass
dann eventuell noch das eine oder andere
schulkind aus werkes unterstützen
da eltern hat die denn den vorteil den
wir gerade diese mit natur und allem
dann eben genauso sehen
das könnte natürlich eine gefahr seien
aber jetzt die nächsten die nächsten
jahre ist es ja auf jeden fall erstmal
gesichert
im sommer tag sich ein silberstreifen am
horizont die schule hat eine lehrerin
und zwar eine die sich darauf freut mit
den kindern möglichst viel draußen zu
sein natürlich werden die behörden
kontrollieren ob sie die lernziele
erfüllt ihr könnt noch der telefoniert
man 21 hier werde ich einfach durch
müsse und wie soll das ganz ganz ganz
wenig haben wir das zu erreichen
mit dem tier tag und rechtsmittel gibt
es über mittag möchte sich mittwoch
donnerstag und samstag am samstagmorgen
das heimische gastronomie da passt ein
schulzimmer haben sie nicht gefunden
aber eine kreative alternative die sie
in kurzer zeit mit crowd funding
finanzieren konnten dort kleben ist
zukünftige schulz ende juli nichts
geschenkt und der user platz oder ganze
platz format ohne das genau schon im
winter die trauma heizen im winter zum
guten glück das wird notwendig sie
lernen sondern auf technischer ebene
man kann es ja kind war darüber sein und
natürlich und rachen zu klinik dicht
machen wenn es gut aus holz auf den
unterlagen beschrieben
da haben wir kreativ danke und dass gott
problemlos ein kleines detail haben die
initianten dabei nicht bedacht eine
jurte darf man nicht einfach so
aufstellen
das dringendste was betroffene
bewilligung für mein weg ist damit wir
endlich anfangen sie jutta lietsch
organisiert oder im mittelfeld zum die
luft stelle
das ist immer mein einziges reisen
wollte die schule ist gregors und
gabriel das herzensprojekt im dorf
äußert man sich grundsätzlich positiv
zum teil nicht aus nur glücklich sie
zieht ihn erinnere kant oder eben
schwere übergang etwas denn toni schuldt
worte sind lied was ich frage noch
selbst das braucht stars die handy auf
fakt ist aber sind eigentlich die schule
auf die beine zu stellen funktionierte
nur dank großer unterstützung
alles war aufwendiger als erwartet wie
so oft bei pionierarbeit der küchenchef
ist überzeugt diese art von schule macht
die kinder teamfähiger und ihr
schulprojekt entspricht einem trend eine
schöne sache
das urvertrauen meiner kinder so weit zu
stärken und natürlich auch von vielen
anderen hoffen wir das ja das
ja dass sich streut mit der zeit
man merkt ja auch die man merkt ja auch
insgesamt ist die ganze entwicklung auch
in der schweiz wie viele solche kleine
projekte gerade in der natur
naturpädagogik viel viel größer
geschrieben wird als sagen wir mal vor
zehn jahren
und am 14 august 2009 10 ist es
tatsächlich soweit nach 19 jahren gehen
auf der rigi wieder kinder zur schule
ich endlich so wie mir hat es geschafft
wenn die bewilligung berufsschule und
riesen atmet ganz einfach endlich los am
ersten schultag sind die eltern wohl
angespannter als die kinder als die
bewilligung vom kanton tatsächlich erst
einen tag vor schulbeginn gekommen ist
das ist den kindern egal
ihr interesse gilt vor allem dem
schulzimmer
das möchte ich ein schulzimmer haben sie
jetzt aber spannender ist es definitiv
draußen begrüße ich ganz ganz herzlich
[Musik]
was ist das leben